Kassie dude if you're gonna write
English sucks at least spell sucks right
Wow Cassie you really had had a tough
time since you started attending
Millwood high first all your childhood
friends ditched you you've had a
relationship drama with Sam and then
your teacher was totally out to get you
in season three we can't wait to see
what happens in season four we have a
feeling your life isn't coming down
anytime soon brats total eclipse is one
of our favorite shows and we got to
wondering about the cast's reel ages and
relationship keep watching to find out
which new cast member Mackenzie Ziggler
is dating turns out the whole dating
someone because they like you thing
isn't a great idea Emily Skinner Emily
Skinner does an amazing job of playing a
mean girl first she was amber on Andy
Mac and now she plays Diana on total
eclipse but she's a total sweetie in
real life Emily is 16 years old although
there have been rumors that she dated
Asher angel all the evidence points to
Emily being single lauren orlando lauren
orlando plays kate the new BFF - the
series star cassie so i'm trying to talk
about things I'm into which crystals
lauren is just 14 years old this is her
first major acting role but you wouldn't
know it because she does such a great
job Lauren is too busy living her best
life to be dating right now she does
star on the show with her real-life
brother though Nadia Turner Jenna is one
of Cassie's other childhood friends who
ditched her at the start of high school
she is played by Nadia Turner Nadia's 15
years old she is focusing on her acting
career instead of dating nadia was
trained as a dancer before she started
acting logan pepper logan pepper plays
Luca who is Kate's love interest in the
first couple of seasons this is
magic Logan is one of the oldest cast
members at age 17 he was on the show
American housewife for two years in
addition to total eclipse he's rumored
to be dating Magath Donnelly but the two
haven't confirmed it yet
Bryce Xavier Bryce's Avior has appeared
in 14 episodes of total eclipse
he plays Scott Bryce is 17 and he just
released his first single this year he's
been acting for a few years
Bryce has dated Nia Sioux from Dance
Moms but it doesn't look like they're
together anymore
annalisa Fisher Annalise's Fischer
played Ana in several episodes of total
eclipse
she is older than most of her cast mates
at age 22 she has also had a guest
appearance on Pretty Little Liars the
perfectionist if Anna Lisa is dating
anyone she's doing a great job at
keeping it a secret maybe she's just too
busy acting Stefan Argus Stefan Argus
plays Julian on total eclipse you might
know him by his nickname Finn Finn is 21
years old he's done a lot of acting and
he was one of the five Kidz Bop kids
from 2011 to 2013
Finn has dated Claudius loose key a
YouTube star
Peyton Hart Hayden Hart is one of the
youngest cast members on total eclipse
she plays Georgia Payton is only 11
years old and is already super
successful she was in clique wars and
several other shows she will also be in
the upcoming movie Anastasia she's super
young so there's no relationship info
yet
Dominic Klein who doesn't love Dominic
Klein
Dominic plays Braden on total eclipse he
is 17 years old
there's no news about him dating anyone
right now he's either really good at
keeping his personal life out of the
press or he's too busy with acting
Dominic has been acting since 2012 you
might have seen him in the movie instant
mom or click Wars
Johnny Orlando Kate's on-screen brother
Sam is the actresses real-life brother
Donny is Lauren Orlando's older brother
he voiced the main character Wyatt in
Super Why from 2015 to 2016
he is also known for his pop song covers
and original songs on
tube Johnny is 16 years old and
currently single
Darius Marcel you know him as Spencer on
total eclipse and you might know him as
Walker from Andy Mac Darius Marcel is a
16 year old actor he is also a dancer
Darius might play love interests in his
shows but right now he is single Lilia
Buckingham although she's not a series
regular no Bratz video would be complete
without a mention of Lilia Buckingham
Malia reprised her role as autumn in
several episodes of total eclipse see
the thing is we need girls who actually
do what they're told her character
autumn has now been in five Brad series
and the movie Spring Break away
Lilia was trained as a dancer she is 16
she used to date Jaden leaver her but
they split recently divinity Perkins
divinity Perkins plays Morgan one of
Cassie's three childhood friends in 2018
divinity was in an episode of last year
she is 16 she is the cousin of chicken
girls actor Jeremiah Perkins earlier
this year a divinity started dating
rapper su generous she has a popular
social media following with her sisters
on accounts called the Perkins sisters
Isaac Presley you might know Isaac
Presley as Ethan from Disney's stuck in
the middle or maybe you watched him as
Bobby on fuller house but Isaac is
joining the cast of total eclipse for
season four he'll be playing a sort of
bad boy character and we are pump Isaac
is 17 he's today Jenna Ortega but now
he's dating his total eclipse co-star
Mackenzie Ziegler the star of total
eclipse is none other than and Mackenzie
Ziggler can you ask me before you tell
someone I'll do something
the actress started out as a dancer on
Dance Moms she also released an album in
2014 she sure has accomplished a lot for
someone who was only 15 years old
sorry gingy shippers she and Johnny
Orlando never dated she is now dating
her new co-star Isaac Presley what do
you think will happen in season 4 of
total eclipse let us know in the
comments thanks for watching be sure to
give this video a big thumbs up and
click that subscribe button for more
great content we'll catch you next time
[Music]